more Republicans want Roy Moore to drop
out of Alabama's Senate race three GOP
senators have rescinded their support
Mike Lee of Utah and Bill Cassidy of
Louisiana criticized the former judges
response to allegations of sexual
misconduct for women confirmed to CBS
News that Moore pursued them when they
were teenagers and he was in his 30s one
accuser says she was 14 years old when
Moore undressed and groped her Manuel
Bojorquez is in Huntsville Alabama where
the Republican nominee says he will not
abandon the race and well good morning
good morning at an event with voters
here last night Roy Moore once again
emphatically denied any wrongdoing and
called the allegations a political
attack his loyal supporters believe him
but it's unclear whether that will be
enough to bring more and Republicans a
victory here next month Roy Moore
arrived at a meeting with voters last
night where the media was kept outside
earlier prominent Republicans called for
him to step down the accusations have
more credibility than the denial I think
it would be best if Roy woods just step
aside I think if the allegations are
true there's no doubt that he should
step aside at his first campaign stop
since the Washington Post published the
story a defiant more continue to deny
the allegations they're desperate this
is this article is a prime example of
fake news the allegations could derail
what was thought to be an easy win for
Republicans who are now grappling with
how to retain the GOP slim majority in
the Senate I think a write-in is
something we should certainly explore I
think Luther strange would be a strong
candidate for a write-in more defeated
Alabama's appointed senator Luther
Strange in the primary this fall with
the help of president Trump's former
chief strategist Steve Bannon it's one
the finest men in this country judge Roy
Moore last week Bannon was quick to come
to Moore's defense it's purely part of
the apparatus of the Democratic Party
but the former White House advisor
didn't mention Moore at all while
speaking at an event last night
in New York City and on the ground in
Alabama he's a man of principle more
supporters say they're prepared to fight
the demands of top Washington
Republicans your support is not wavering
at this point not at all
not
in fact it's stronger than ever this
weekend a number of White House
officials distance themselves from more
but stop short of saying they believe
the allegations are true meanwhile the
Senate GOP campaign arm has already
ended its fundraising agreement with
more Charlie thanks Manuel